come on it's a party tonight my man look
look
they're losing their the energy here
it's amazing it was like it's on set
every single day
no seriously though i mean when you you
know i'm old enough to be their fathers
not that i am but you know it's it's a
crazy crazy thing to be on set with
young this young this gifted this
talented this generous and kind and it's
like
every day is a very lively lovely
energized and focused and brilliant to
watch today tom holland just almost
jumped in your lap there gave a big old
smooch well we know each other of all
we're you know with two brits who are
having the rights of our lives and you
know it's just fun to share a little bit
of it with him and uh i'm really proud
of him i know it sounds patronizing but
you know he's younger than me like i
said before and to get to see him from
the moment i remember him bounding
across the concrete at long crosses
awful studio we have to shoot a lot of
marvel stuff in england
hello i'm tom i'm i've just been cast
into spider-man i was like
wow congratulations that's amazing i
mean i knew about his work in billy
elliot i knew he had the chops for it
but you know now he is so thrown into
this like amazing leading man you know
it is cool to see i agree with you
that's
wonderful of the ride of your life you
know you got a lot of love for the power
of the dog this morning by the way of
award nominations how does that feel oh
it's it's it's wonderful
it's wonderful um
yeah my smile says more than i can about
it you know it's it's a recognition of
work and that's a joyous thing is to be
celebrated and
yeah just a very very lovely moment the
mind of marvel is like the best thing
ever like
it's just
i mean can you even put it into words
like what they do what they come up with
where these stories go how they're
crafted
it's a really you know
i think if i had a superpower it would
probably be to be the victoria
louis or kevin i i you know they really
are
masters of storytelling and
you know there's a lot of stuff talked
about the big affair in the culture at
the moment squeezing out the smaller by
the way that's always been the case i
mean i i was a kid i wanted to see the
next bomb film i wanted to see the next
indiana jones film and yet here i am you
know equally in love with the work of
jane camping as i am john watts it's you
know i think there's there's room for
all of it at the table
and i think the very best of it is
mythical storytelling if and so to be a
part of that and to watch it and to just
marvel no pun intended at it is it's
kind of extraordinary like you say it's
there's
it's a headache to think of how they
pre-consider i think a lot of stuff is
retro-engineered i think they'll be the
first to admit that wholeheartedly
but you know there's just as much
creativity in doing that as having
everything on a storyboard before you
start a day shoot you know and i think
um
it's the amount of resources they have
but the amount of flexibility and
playfulness and enjoyment they still
have in their jobs that really speaks to
how successful it is